six mois après il a encore du mal à s'y
faire
donc voilà une partie des ternes qui
actuellement est fermée qui représente
normalement 40 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires annuel la piscine et le spa
reste désespérément vide depuis le 15
mars dernier pour raisons sanitaires
seule activité qui a repris cet été la
thur thermale
mais là aussi en raison du contexte
impossible d'accueillir plus de 45
curistes en simultané l'impression que
cette s'est privatisé et j'ai appelé mes
parents pour leur dire que vraiment que
qui viennent parce que je aussi pour une
cure et ils ont ils avaient peur dont
son palais mais j'aurais dit c'est
vraiment l'année il faut la faire parce
que c'est tranquille c'est bien on prend
son temps
conséquence les comptes des termes de
salins les bains à vire au rouge vif
jusqu'à 120 mille euros de pertes par
mois pendant le confinement 75000 depuis
la réouverture pour ne rien arranger ses
installations quasi neuf ont été
financées à crédit il y a trois ans mais
est obligé de verser les salaires
complètement
avec zéro recettes aujourd'hui on a des
remboursements de capital et d'intérêts
qui sont quand même assez énorme sur
notre structure et
donc on a eu des pertes estimées sur
chaque mois d'inactivité aux alentours
de 500 mille euros une baisse d'activité
qui n'est pas sans conséquence pour les
commerces du centre-ville dans cette
brasserie
si la sauce y assure avoir connu un bon
mois d'août il plonge dans l'inconnu cet
automne les curistes sont là mais le
grand public qui est d un petit peu ce
pratiquement divisé par 2 quoi donc on
le sent forcément dans notre activité
les termes étant municipaux n'ont pas pu
bénéficier du dispositif des deux
entreprises a annoncé par le
gouvernement pendant le confinement
le maire de la commune entend bien
réparer ce qu'il estime être une
injustice on entend parler de
compensation dont beaucoup beaucoup de
domaines dont beaucoup de filières
effectivement nous on souhaite aussi
bénéficié ces compensations pour limiter
nos pertes en fin d'année des pertes
colossales estimé à 1 million d'euros en
2020 un tiers du chiffre d'affaires des
thermes